stellen Sie sich vor sie werden verfolgt
ein mächtiger Geheimdienst ist ihnen auf
den Fersen
[Musik]
sie bekommen Todesdrohungen sie müssen
Angst haben um Frau und Kinder sowie der
türkische Journalist John dünnda den der
Präsident seines Heimatlandes jagen
lässt
und diese Person wird einen hohen Preis
bezahlt ich werde ihn nicht straflos
davonkommen lassen
[Musik]
seit den Protesten am Istanbuler
gesi-park 2013 greift Erdogan hart durch
nach einem Putschversuch drei Jahre
später lässt er tausende im Land
verhaften auch außerhalb der Türkei
gehen Erdogans Leute brutal gegen
Kritiker vor Entführungen Angriffe
seiner Bodyguards
der Alleinherrscher schaut seine Wähler
hinter sich
[Musik]
sie sagen ich gehe zu hart vor tut mir
leid dieser Teil erdogan ist so und er
wird sich nicht ändern
2016 wird auf John dünnda geschossen er
muss nach Deutschland fliehen aber auch
hier hat Erdogan fanatische Anhänger
wir haben Sie in der Türkei fertig
gemacht und jetzt machen wir sie in
Deutschland fertig
wer Erdogan mit seiner Kritik zu nahe
kommt landet wie John dünnda auf einer
Fahndungsliste der türkischen Regierung
als angeblicher Terrorist
[Musik]
das ist die Liste wenn sie auf die
Belohnung klicken sehen Sie wie viel
Geld sie bekommen wenn die Leute
verhaftet werden
die haben Geld auf meinen Kopf
ausgesetzt so wie im Wilden Westen das
steht da ganz offen auf deren Website
[Musik]
Berlin Schöneberg
als John dünndar 2016 aus seiner Heimat
fliehen muss verliert er fast alles
seine Wohnung in Istanbul seine
Ersparnisse seine Karriere als
Chefredakteur einer großen türkischen
Zeitung
deshalb erzählt diese Geschichte auch
seine eigene Geschichte
und sieben Jahre später kurz vor den
Präsidentschaftswahlen in der Türkei ist
sie der ganz besondere Blick eines
Journalisten im Exil auf sein Land
ich habe immer davon geträumt Journalist
zu werden obwohl das sehr gefährlich ist
ein Bild aus meiner Zeit als Enkelmann
ich habe die hauptnachrichtensendung des
Senders NTV präsentiert
ehrlich gesagt waren das glückliche
Zeiten
[Musik]
und das sind Bilder von den Protesten am
gesipark das war der Wendepunkt nicht
nur für die Türkei auch für mich
da wurde Erdogan zum Autokraten und von
da an änderte sich alles
als Chefredakteur der Tageszeitung Jim
höre jetzt deckte John dünnda Erdogan
Skandale auf auch über türkische
Waffenlieferungen angihadisten in Syrien
die
Opposition feiert ihn damals die Justiz
steckt ihn ins Gefängnis als er nach
drei Monaten frei kommt schäumt Erdogan
ich akzeptiere diese Entscheidung nicht
und ich respektiere sie nicht
dann das Attentat nur eines von vielen
auf türkische Journalisten in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten
es ist wirklich ein gefährlicher Beruf
geworden nicht nur das Schreiben eine
Artikels schon ein Tweet kann ihr Leben
bedrohen
das meint nicht nur Regierungskräfte
Staatsanwälte Richter auch einfache
Leute auf der Straße können sie
angreifen
erdogan hat den Menschen diesen Hass
gegeben entweder bist du auf meiner
Seite oder du bist mein fein
nach seiner Flucht lässt sich die
deutsche Politprominenz gern mit
Dünndarm fotografieren ein paar Jahre
später App das Interesse ab wohl auch
aus Furcht vor diesem Mann
wo auch immer Erdogan in Deutschland
Termine hat macht er Stimmung gegen
seine Kritiker das seien keine
Journalisten sondern Terroristen die man
endlich ausliefern solle an die Türkei
[Musik]
für diesen Film sind wir mit gepanzerten
Wagen und Personenschützern des LKA
Berlin unterwegs weil Jan dünnda nach
wie vor bedroht wird
die Recherche wird uns von Deutschland
über Schweden und Frankreich bis nach
Argentinien führen dort sitzt der Mann
im Knast der John dünnda 2016 wohl
eigentlich erschießen sollte
[Musik]
unser erster Gesprächspartner heißt
Jeffery Güven ein Journalist und Blogger
dessen Videos sich in Deutschland und
der Türkei Millionen im Internet
anschauen
aus seiner Heimat musste Güven fliehen
weil er Erdogan für dessen harsche
Kurdenpolitik offen kritisiert das kann
in der Türkei reichen um seines Lebens
nicht mehr sicher zu sein
alles gut
mir geht's gut danke
wir sind auf der Autobahn wahrscheinlich
sind wir so in drei Stunden bei dir du
bist zu Hause oder nicht
zu ich würde gern zwei von den
Personenschützern mit in die Wohnung
bringen wenn das für dich okay ist
die beiden Männer kennen sich seit
Jahren aber getroffen haben sie sich
noch nie
wir waren im selben Gefängnis zur selben
Zeit wir haben uns nie gesehen weil das
in so einem Gefängnis nicht geht aber
Nachrichten konnten wir austauschen
eine Kleinstadt in Hessen deren Namen
wir nicht nennen dürfen aus
Sicherheitsgründen hier lebt Severin mit
seiner Frau und zwei Kindern angeblich
in großem Luxus das behaupten Medien die
Erdogan nahe stehen
hallo wie geht's
wenigstens müssen wir uns dieses Mal
nicht durch das abflussgitter
unterhalten
die beiden Männer die da miteinander
Scherzen haben schwere Zeiten
durchgemacht nicht gemeinsam aber in
zwei nebeneinander liegenden Zellen in
einem berüchtigten türkischen
gefängnisredakteure für die
Opposition aufrechte Journalisten für
die Regierung Erdogan Terroristen
[Musik]
in der Türkei wurde Güven zu 22 Jahren
Haft verurteilt für diese satirische
Titelseite eine Fotomontage von Erdogan
vor einem Sarg genau
dieses Cover haben wir 2015 gemacht das
war ein sehr blutiges Jahr
bei den Wahlen nicht genügend Stimmen
bekommen um allein regieren zu können
deshalb begann er einen Angriff auf die
Kurden
gleich gemacht und mit jedem Toten stieg
die Zustimmung für Erdogans Partei AKP
wieder an kapakster
kaum ein anderes Thema spaltet die
Türkei mehr als der Kurdenkonflikt
seitdem Erdogan dort Hubschrauber und
Panzer einsetzt ist es noch gefährlicher
geworden sein hartes Vorgehen zu
kritisieren wer ist trotzdem tot muss
mit Verfolgung rechnen
und seine Kollegen haben sich davon
nicht abschrecken lassen
diejenigen die diese Titelseite gemacht
haben sind unehrenhaft das sind Schurken
und deshalb werde ich tun was notwendig
ist
das war eine klare Ansage dass uns etwas
passieren würde schon am nächsten Tag
stand die Polizei in der Redaktion
es gibt Bilder von der Festnahme oder
nicht
da ist mein Stellvertreter er ist immer
noch im Gefängnis und das bin ich das
sind die Bilder von unserer Festnahme
[Musik]
zwei Monate im Gefängnis und du warst
mein Zellen Nachbar nur eine Wand war
zwischen uns
2016 Flo die Familie nach Deutschland
endlich zur Ruhe kommen mit einer
kleinen Wohnung einem Sprachkurs für die
Ehefrau und einer Zukunft für die Kinder
doch Anfang dieses Jahres landet Güven
plötzlich auf Erdogans Terrorliste als
einer von 1.300 gesuchten
schon ein paar Monate vorher prangte
sein Foto auf der Titelseite der größten
türkischen Boulevardzeitung
22 September
hier sieht man unser Haus das sind Fotos
aus dem Inneren der Wohnung
war das eine geheimdienst-operation
sieht danach aus
wie sie die Fotos gemacht haben dass wir
uns überhaupt gefunden haben das sieht
weniger nach Journalisten aus das war
der Geheimdienst
und wer diese roten Linien überschreitet
dem passiert was
unsere Wohnung im türkischen Fernsehen
gezeigt
es ist jemand der geheime tonmitschnitte
gemacht hat
das ist unser Haus von außen
jemand der Chefredakteur der Zeitschrift
noctav wurde und sehr provokante Cover
verantwortet hat
am Anfang hatten wir in Deutschland
keine Probleme aber nachdem mein
YouTube-Kanal so erfolgreich wurde gab
es eine Welle von drohunger
und wenn Sie meine Adresse
veröffentlichen spricht das natürlich
jeden Fanatiker im Land an das setzt uns
unter großen Druck es besteht
Lebensgefahr für uns und unsere Kinder
reingehen es wird gesäubert
wie kann es sein dass ein türkischer
Präsident Hass und Hetze bis in eine
deutsche Kleinstadt trägt
wir sind verabredet mit dem
Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen wo
besonders viele Anhänger Erdogans leben
in Dutzenden Mails haben wir politiker
und Sicherheitsbehörden für ein
Interview angefragt
Herbert Reul ist der einzige der sich
zur Lage türkischer Dissidenten vor die
Kamera traut
der türkische Staat versucht direkt oder
auch indirekt über Organisationen
Einfluss auf solche Menschen zu nehmen
das ist offenkundig und das geht nicht
bei uns ist ein Land der Freiheit der
Demokratie der Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
jeder der sich an die Regeln dieses
Staates hält kann hier leben und auch
seine Meinung äußern
Aufmarsch in Köln 2016 ein buntes
Spektakel doch hinter den Kulissen wüten
regelmäßig Erdogans Funktionäre wie
Anfang des Jahres in Neuss
wir haben Sie in der Türkei fertig
gemacht und jetzt machen wir sie in
Deutschland fertig
so bahnt sich Erdogans Hetze ihren Weg
von Ankara nach Deutschland
das ist in der Türkei passiert finde ich
nicht akzeptabel ist nicht meine Politik
auf der anderen Seite lerne ich aber
auch dass die Türkei für die Frage von
Stabilität in der Weltgesellschaft nicht
ganz unwichtig ist und auch für die
Frage von Flüchtlingspolitik eine
wichtige Rolle gespielt haben wenn man
darf nicht vergessen dass die türkische
Politik das heißt auch Regierung uns
auch geholfen hat in der Frage
flüchtlingströme dass die Belastung für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht so
groß geworden ist wie sie hätte werden
können und das macht schwer
jeder Politiker in Deutschland weiß dass
viele hierzulande Angst haben vor
Bildern wie diesen überfüllte Lager von
geflüchteten in der Türkei
aber darf die deutsche Politik es
deshalb hinnehmen dass Erdogans Kritiker
bei uns verfolgt werden nur weil der
droht dass die Schlauchboote mit seinem
Segen wieder fahren
sie haben keine Ahnung von
internationaler Politik und Diplomatie
sie sind nervös und feige sie sind
Nachkommen der Nazis sie sind Faschisten
in jeder deutschen Großstadt gibt es
Viertel wie Berlin Kreuzberg in denen
Menschen wie John dünnder nicht sicher
sind denn von drei Millionen
türkischstämmigen Bürgern im Land dürfen
1,5 Millionen in der Türkei wählen und
mehr als die Hälfte steht hinter Erdogan
Germany ist die muss dangerous country
in Deutschland ist für jemanden wie mich
das gefährlichste Land der Welt und
Berlin ist einer der gefährlichsten Orte
der türkische Geheimdienst ist hier sehr
aktiv und es gibt hier viele die von
Erdogan mit Hass gefüttert wurden
leider hat die deutsche Regierung in
jahrzehntelang gewähren lassen deshalb
spiegelt sich die Polarisierung in der
Türkei in Deutschland direkt wieder
in türki direct in Germany
überall können politische Fanatiker
lauern
Einschüchterungsversuche per Handyvideo
ich Filme sie
ich kenne sie deshalb ich Filme sie auch
sie sind doch der Verräter
ein türkischer Sender schickte sogar
einen Reporter nach Berlin und
veröffentlichte die Büroadresse von John
Döner
wir gehen langsam hoch mal sehen ob wir
ein Treffen
hallo
sie können nicht mit ihm reden er ist
nicht da
bitte
er ist nicht da sie müssen einen Termin
machen
wer bei Sicherheitsbehörden und
politisch Verantwortlichen nachfragt
bekommt regelmäßig zu hören es sei
schwierig gegen Hass und Hetze im Netz
vorzugehen
doch wenn die Täter nicht ermittelt
werden bleibt es womöglich nicht bei
Handyvideos und Drohungen
[Musik]
wenn ich hier meinen Namen rein schreibe
und auf Suchen drücke werden sie den
Shitstorm sehen
eine der Nachrichten kommt von jemanden
namens Metin wir wissen nicht ob das ein
echter Name ist oder nicht aber er hat
dieses Bild zu seinem Tweet hinzugefügt
und schreibt das ist das Ende das auf
dich wartet das ist
das Foto zeigt vielleicht zehn Leichname
von Menschen wahrscheinlich getötet von
türkischen Soldaten
[Musik]
nicht nur in Deutschland leben türkische
Dissidenten gefährlich
[Musik]
in ganz Europa macht Erdogan Druck
es to meet with peop wir sind auf dem
Weg nach Stockholm und Menschen zu
treffen die von der türkischen Regierung
verfolgt werden
mit den Schweden verhandelt Erdogan
gerade über deren Mitgliedschaft in der
NATO dafür verlangt er dass seine Gegner
ausgeliefert werden
eine sehr schwierige Situation
[Musik]
der Krieg in der Ukraine Erdogan weiß
ihn für sich zu nutzen gegenüber
Schweden und Finnland tritt er mit
aggressiven Forderungen auf so versucht
er sich zu Hause als starker Mann zu
profilieren im Kampf gegen seine Feinde
keiner von den beiden Staaten hat doch
einen klaren Standpunkt gegenüber
Terroristen
[Musik]
eine Gemeinde in der Nähe von Stockholm
wir treffen einen Mann der erlebt hat
was passiert wenn man ins Visier
türkischer Fanatiker Gerät Ahmed Dönmez
ein Journalist
[Musik]
am 18 März 2022 bin ich mittags zur
Schule gefahren um meine Tochter
abzuholen wir waren auf dem Rückweg
genau an dieser Stelle sie kam von da
genau
und als wir hier sind fährt uns ein
anderes Auto hinten drauf ich steige aus
um zu sehen was passiert ist aber all
das weiß ich nur von meiner Tochter
[Musik]
sie erinnern sich an nichts
ich erinnere mich nicht an den Angriff
meine Tochter hatte später so erzählt
ein Auto hat unser Auto angefahren du
hast gesagt ja gibt's denn sowas dann
bist du ausgestiegen
meine Tochter saß angeschnallt im
Kindersitz hinter unserem Auto stand ein
weißes Auto hat sie später erzählt aber
was dein Volk sieht sie nicht mehr weil
sie sich wieder nach vorne umdreht
zum Glück denn später konnten wir
rekonstruieren dass ich in genau diesem
Moment auf den Kopf geschlagen wurde mit
einem harten Gegenstand
[Musik]
drei Wochen lag Ahmed Dönmez im
Krankenhaus
Schädelfraktur samtschädel hirntrauma
mit etwas weniger Glück hätte er den
Angriff nicht überlebt
[Musik]
seitdem lebt die Familie in Angst in dem
Haus dessen Adresse die Schläger jetzt
kennen
[Musik]
warum steht ihr Name auf der Terrorliste
ich stehe auf dieser Liste weil ich
Journalist bin weil ich kritische
Artikel schreibe
ich habe Bücher über die Korruption und
der Erdogan geschrieben über ein
geheimes System das er in seiner Zeit
als Bürgermeister aufgebaut hat
er reagierte darauf sehr heftig auch die
AKP und seine Anhänger nahmen mich ins
Visier als sie meine Bücher
beschlagnahmen wollten fühlte ich mich
in der Türkei nicht mehr sicher
2015 floh die Familie aus der Türkei und
beantragte politisches Asyl für Ahmed
dönnies und seine Frau steht fest dass
sie nicht mehr zurück wollen
doch Anfang des Jahres fand sich der
Journalist plötzlich auf Erdogans
Terrorliste wieder warum auf einmal
kurz vor dem Anschlag auf mich habe ich
sehr viel auf YouTube veröffentlicht
Videos über Beziehungen von
Innenminister Sulejman Soylu und
mehreren polizeischiffs zu mafia-gruppen
in Ankara
Video
kann sein einer der Mafia Bosse hat mir
damals eine Todesdrohung geschickt denk
nicht stand da dass du in Schweden
sicher bist wenn ich will kann ich dir
innerhalb von 24 Stunden den Kopf
abschlagen lassen auch in Schweden
als ich das gelesen habe bin ich zur
Polizei und habe Anzeige erstattet 10
Tage später kam es zu dem Angriff auf
mich
nach dem Überfall Laden Mitglieder der
türkischen Mafia diese Bilder im
Internet hoch dazu schreiben Sie Ahmed
Dönmez hat bekommen was er verdient hat
zum Jahrestag hat ihm seine Tochter ein
Herz aus Papier gebastelt
das hat sie mir am 18 März geschenkt am
Jahrestag des Überfalls da steht alles
Gute zu deinem ersten Geburtstag Papa
weil ich damals fast gestorben wäre ist
das jetzt mein erster Geburtstag
meine Frau macht sich große Sorgen sie
fühlt sich hier nicht mehr sicher und
ich konnte lange Zeit nicht schreiben
aber das Leben geht weiter wir müssen
unsere Arbeit machen
die Universität von Stockholm wir
treffen den Direktor des Instituts für
türkei-studien seit einem Jahr
beobachtet Paul telewin wie sich das
türkische Verhältnis zu Schweden und
Europa verändert
viele Jahre lang hat sich die Türkei um
den Beitritt zur Europäischen Union
bemüht da musst du die Türkei viel
ertragen weil Schweden und andere Länder
der EU Sie ständig über Menschenrechte
belehrt haben
auf einmal hat sich der Spieß umgedreht
das kommt Erdogan politisch zugute bei
Wahlen anstehen und ein sehr harter
Wahlkampf vor ihm liegt
und diese neue Rolle da sehr effizient
für sich nutzen
das ist nicht überraschend dass ein
Autokrat Menschenrechte in Frage stellt
aber es überrascht doch dass eine
Regierung wie die schwedische mit einem
Autokraten über Menschenrechtsfragen
verhandelt
bei der türkischen Außenpolitik unter
Erdogan geht es darum Zugeständnisse zu
machen um dann Deals aus behandeln wenn
man Druckmittel hat
leverage
bei den Auslieferungen zum Beispiel gibt
es das trilaterale Memorandum das
Schweden Finnland und die Türkei im Juni
ausgehandelt haben
dieses Abkommen macht es Schweden und
Finnland leichter in die NATO zu kommen
im Gegenzug werden schwedische Gerichte
und Behörden verpflichtet künftig
türkische Auslieferungsanträge zu
prüfence
der russische Angriffskrieg eröffnet
Erdogan ganz neue machtoptionen
plötzlich werden seine Kontakte zu Putin
gebraucht für mögliche Verhandlungen
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
aus der internationalen Krise könnte
Erdogan so politisches Kapital schlagen
und andere Länder unter Druck setzen
[Musik]
unsere zweite Nacht in Stockholm seit
Wochen versuchen wir ein Interview mit
einem schwedischen Spitzenpolitiker zu
bekommen bislang vergebens
hi Wie geht's so I just wanna ich wollte
wegen des Interviews Nachfragen haben
wir irgendeine Antwort bekommen
die
ehemalige Außenministerin will nicht
reden richtig
jetzt
ist so enttäuschend zu sehen wie sie
sich vor einem Diktator verbeugen
ja
am Tag darauf sind wir mit einer
ehemaligen Abgeordneten des schwedischen
Parlaments verabredet ihr falls zeigt
besonders gut wie Erdogan außenpolitisch
Druck macht und Jagd auf seine Kritiker
Armine ist Kurden stammt aus dem Iran
und besitzt seit Jahren die schwedische
Staatsbürgerschaft
[Musik]
wie sie auf der Liste derjenigen landen
konnte die Schweden an Erdogan
ausliefern soll ist der ehemaligen
Abgeordneten schleierhaft
die ganze Zeit über haben türkische
Medien behauptet im schwedischen
Parlament gäbe es eine Terroristin seit
2015 bedrohen mich die türkischen
Faschisten von den grauen Wölfen und
schicken mir E-Mails
genau
regierungsfreundlicher Sender und die
Reden über sie im türkischen Fernsehen
korrigiert er sich und sagt sie seien
von der PKK und Abgeordnete im
schwedischen Parlament
ich war nie politisch aktiv in einer
türkischen oder kurdischen Organisation
in der Türkei ich komme aus dem Iran ich
war nie türkische Staatsbürgerin ich
habe mich nie in der türkischen
Opposition engagiert
aber die benutzen Fotos von ihnen um zu
zeigen dass sie eine Terroristin sind
ich war bei der peschmerger im
kurdischen Teil des Iran ich habe
niemanden getötet
die iranische Regierung war hinter mir
her ich war 13 Jahre alt und musste in
die Berge fliehen um zu überleben
immer wieder habe ich den Journalisten
erklärt erdogan will Schweden nur
erpressen
Politik als Erpressungsversuch erst
verlangt Erdogan die Auslieferung einer
schwedischen Abgeordneten und erhöht
damit den Druck auf deren Regierung dann
gibt er ein wenig nach nur um später
vielleicht doch noch die Abschiebung
anderer Exil Türken durchsetzen zu
können
[Musik]
aus anderen Ländern werden türkische
Exilanten einfach verschleppt und zu
Hause mit solchen Fotos öffentlich
vorgeführt
Malaysia 2017 ein türkischer
Staatsbürger wird in einer Tiefgarage
entführt
Kosovo 2018 eine türkische Familie wird
auf der Ausfallstraße gestoppt der Vater
mitgenommen
Moldau 2018 türkische Staatsbürger
werden gekidnappt und in ihr Heimatland
gebracht und Erdogan lässt sich für die
Jagd auf politische Gegner bejubeln
isten die geflohen sind bringen wir
einzeln zurück und übergeben sie der
Justiz unseres Landes
vor dem Krieg die rücksichtslos Erdogan
selbst frühere Gefolgsleute verfolgt
zeigt dieser Fall
Noriker kann bosquier war Elite Soldat
und an Waffenlieferungen nach Syrien
beteiligt jetzt soll er plötzlich ein
Mörder sein
[Musik]
unser Geheimdienst hat den wegen Mordes
gesuchten Nuri gökernboskier in der
Ukraine aufgespürt nur die Gökhan ist
die Parade und diese Person festnehmen
und in die Türkei zurückbringen zu
lassen
habe ich mit präsidentiellenski
gesprochen
e Stück
2015 war boskia in die Ukraine geflohen
und hatte ausgepackt über türkische
waffendeals mit Jihadisten für Erdogan
Verrat doch die Ukraine lehnt seine
Auslieferung ab weil die Beweise gegen
den angeblichen Mörder nicht reichen
dann greift Russland die Ukraine an und
die Regierung selenski braucht dringend
moderne Waffen
[Musik]
Erdogan lässt Kampfdrohnen liefern
und plötzlich wird Boss hier in die
Türkei verschleppt dort offenbar
gefoltert und der Öffentlichkeit
vorgeführt Erdogan persönlich verkündet
den Erfolg
verdächtigt und steht jetzt vor Gericht
schon
auf diese oder ähnliche Weise hat die
Regierung Erdogan seit 2016 mehr als 100
Menschen verschleppen lassen aus
mittlerweile 21 Ländern weltweit
[Musik]
zurück in Berlin Schöneberg
bei John dünnda ist eine Mail aus
Argentinien eingetroffen an die wir
schon nicht mehr geglaubt hatten
es ist für mich immer gefährlich
Deutschland zu verlassen aber
Argentinien soll sicher sein
monatelang haben wir uns um die
Drehgenehmigung für ein argentinisches
Gefängnis bemüht jetzt ist sie da
i'm sorry
ich bin so aufgeregt was für ein
Interview so etwas gibt es nur einmal im
Leben da ist jemand der sie vor ein paar
Jahren umbringen sollte
plötzlich treffen sie den in einer
Gefängniszelle für ein Interview
was Schönes
ich habe ein paar Bilder von diesem Mann
er hat in Syrien gekämpft gegen die
syrische Regierung
[Musik]
spannend ist ich habe ja damals über
türkische Waffenlieferungen an Syrien
geschrieben dafür wurde ich verurteilt
und er war dabei als diese Waffen in
Syrien verteilt worden er ist also ein
Zeuge meiner Story von damals
2015 veröffentlicht John dünder den
Artikel der im später eine Verurteilung
zu 27 Jahren Haft einbringen wird und
sein Leben zerstört
[Musik]
Waffenlieferungen aus der Türkei
angihadisten in Syrien ein
internationaler Skandal der dünner
schließlich ins Exil treibt
[Musik]
was wird in der Mann mit der
Kalaschnikow erzählen wer wollte ihn
damals umbringen lassen und was haben
seine Recherchen zu den waffendeals
damit zu tun
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt in Buenos Aires wo ich
das interessanteste Interview meines
Lebens führen werde ich treffe den Mann
der mich eigentlich umbringen sollte
sein Name ist Serkan der wird des Mordes
der Entführung und des Raubes
verdächtigt
er steht auf der interpolliste und ist
ein Mann der viel weiß Andi
2020 wurde Serkan cortulus in Buenos
Aires verhaftet der Verdacht schwere
Straftaten für ein kriminelles Netzwerk
in der Türkei
angeblich seien darin auch führende
Parteifunktionäre Erdogans und
Angehörige des türkischen Geheimdienstes
verwickelt das behauptet Kurtulus der
nach eigenen Angaben auch John Dünndarm
umbringen sollte seit drei Jahren sitzt
er im Gefängnis
dass wir hier drehen dürfen verdanken
wir dem Anwalt von Kurtulus der hat die
Sache vorangetrieben aber warum
wie weit können wir den Aussagen eines
Mannes trauen der alles tun würde um
nicht an die Türkei ausgeliefert zu
werden
mit seinem roten T-Shirt und dem Lächeln
sieht Kurtulus beinahe harmlos aus doch
dieser Eindruck täuscht so viel ist
sicher
wer wollte mich töten und warum
damals war der Leiter des Geheimdienstes
in Izmir zudem hatte ich Kontakt
er sagte mir dass sie ein Vaterlands
Verräter sind dass sie wegen ihres
Artikels über die Waffenlieferungen
bestraft werden müssen und dass sich der
richtige sei um den Anschlag
auszuführener
dafür würde man mich in der Türkei zum
Helden erklären die höchsten Behörden
würden mich schützen
als ich auf den Vorschlag nicht sofort
einging
so drei bis fünf Tage vielleicht eine
Woche vor dem Anschlag auf Sie
[Musik]
weil ich den Auftrag nicht angenommen
habe schickte mir ein Mafia Boss am
nächsten Tag eine Nachricht den Namen
möchte ich lieber nicht nennen
sie haben also diesen Mafiaboss als
Vermittler eingeschaltet und der schrieb
noch mal dass sie ein Vaterlandsverräter
sind und er verlangte von mir dass ich
den Auftrag übernehmen den Anschlag auf
Sie
das Attentat auf dünnda hat am Ende ein
anderer ausgeführt ob es stimmt was
Kurtulus im Gefängnis erzählt dass
eigentlich eher schießen sollte lässt
sich am Ende nicht beweisen aber viele
Indizien sprechen dafür
wenn ich an die Türkei ausgeliefert
werde wird die AKP sagen Serkan was du
ausgesagt hast musst du widerrufen
stattdessen wirst du das aussagen was
wir Dir sagen
gehe ich darauf ein verläuft alles im
Sande wenn nicht werden sie mich zum
Schweigen bringen wir wissen doch alle
das wichtige Zeugen in türkischen
Gefängnissen verschwinden
Schlägertrupps
es gibt viele Zeugen und Indizien für
den Verdacht dass sich einflussreiche
Politiker Funktionäre und
Geheimdienstler verbündet haben um die
Türkei auszuplündern aber wer will das
noch hören
[Musik]
Paris das Gebäude der
Nationalversammlung hier trifft John
dünnda türkische Dissidenten von denen
eine ganze Reihe auf Erdogans
terroristisch stehen um darüber zu reden
wie es weitergehen soll nach den Wahlen
in der Türkei
[Musik]
was passiert am 14 Mai oder besser am 15
Mai
bist
das ist die große Frage denn diese Wahl
ist nicht irgendeine Wahl
für Menschen wie uns für alle die in der
Türkei im Gefängnis sitzen geht es am 14
mai um Leben und Tod
im Grunde genommen ist das der Tag an
dem sich die Türkei entscheidet zwischen
Autokratie und Demokratie
wenn die Türkei ein demokratisches Land
wäre wäre die Antwort auf Ihre Frage
einfach die Meinungsumfragen sagen dass
Erdogan die Wahl verlieren wird zum
ersten Mal gibt es eine große Koalition
gegen Erdogan
[Musik]
die türkische Großstadt ist mir wenige
Tage vor der Wahl
mehr als 700.000 Menschen auf der Straße
um Erdogans wahlgegner zu unterstützen
doch nach 20 Jahren der Herrschaft ist
das Land gespalten die einen sehen in
Erdogan nach wie vor einen Heilsbringer
die anderen einen rücksichtslosen
Autokraten der jeden verfolgen lässt der
seine Macht in Frage stellt
[Musik]